Uh, there's one more thing that I want to maybe talk about before I even go, uh,
into this, uh, this is the best the, the, the, the, the,
the spring, the spring breakers,
Florida spring breakers, Dr. Dena Grayson tweeted. If I get, well,
she was just tweeting about this, basically letting people know,
and every tweeted it, but these kids on spring break,
this was like days after they told people that it was a bad, bad thing.
These idiots, dude.
I get Corona. I get Corona at the end of the day.
I'm not going to let it stop me from partying. You know, I've been waiting,
we've been waiting for Miami spring break for awhile, but.
Okay, fine. But also this isn't about you.
And I don't expect you to know that, but I'm just telling you,
you're going to spread it and people are going to die.
I'm not done with that sentence. You idiot. Okay. Now I am.
I'm also the guy who's saying it is. So the guy who would be saying it,
I can't believe it. It's so crazy.
Multicloud trip, two, three months. Where's that you're having a good time.
Whatever happens happens.
Happens. People die, people die. Look at this girl, this idiot.
Spring break, spring break, but how privileged,
what is there to do here other than go to the bars or the beach?
And they're closing all of it. It's really maximum.
I think they're blowing it way out of proportion.
I think it's doing way too much is bad. We need a refund.
There's Laura St that serious. It's serious.
It's more serious things out there like hunger.
Some more serious things out there. That's the best.
One time I was on the road with my friend, Jason Collins,
and we asked a security guard where there's a Starbucks because of the Starbucks
we were close to is closed. And I said, and we said, Hey,
do you know where there's Starbucks? And he said,
it's another Starbucks down the block. And we never stopped saying it.
It's another Starbucks, Starbucks, Starbucks.
It's another Starbucks, a few blocks down. It's another Starbucks dude.
What's wrong with theirs. Even the subtitles on this, fixed it. They wrote,
there's more serious things out there. And he wrote,
it's more serious things out there.
Ain't that serious. It's serious.
It's more serious things out there like hunger and poverty.
We need to address that.
ESR the cronies dude.
A long time ago. And it was kind of up in the air for you. So go by, like,
we're here. I just turned 21 this year. So I'm here to parties.
She sound like that.
That's the most annoying voice in the world.
Dude. Imagine dating that girl. I don't know.
I just feel like if we watch the last, if we watch it,
you know, now if we start watching it now,
I'd rather just wait until it's all done. And then we can stream it.
Every episode each after another, this way,
you don't have to wait every Sunday to watch. And that's some she'd say,
why can't we just wait until game of Thrones is over completely.
Then we can just stream.
It all together. This way we can watch it whenever we want to.
And we don't have to wait every Sunday.
How did she make every word sound? The same? It's she's the,
basically the she's making every word rhyme. She's like,
she's like the female Eminem. This girl, this girl, miss her calling, dude.
She's she should rhyme orange with door hinge. Poverty. We need this girl.
Yeah. I mean, we planned this a long time ago and it was kind of up in the air.
Yeah. I mean, my plan as a long time I got, and I was kinda
[inaudible] every syllables. The same. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
Aye. Aye.
Aye. She does King's speech.
This is King speeches daughter, dude. This is King speeches.
Daughter. God,
I'm the biggest idiot on the earth.
I can't believe you listened to this podcast. It's so stupid.
And we keep going.
Dude. And we won't stop.
I got a little tussle, a hair that went in front of my face when I said that.
And that's so sexy, man.
Imagine me on top of you and we're doing it and you could be male or female.
This isn't about gay or straight. I don't give a fantasize about me right now.
Me on top of you and it's sweaty and it feels real good.
And I'm doing slow swoop down, dude. I don't do bang at a bang at a bank.
I don't like that. In fact, I never. I only made love even with hookers.
Never had one, but I'm just saying if I were going to, I would make love.
I don't care if I have to pay you afterwards.
I don't it's you know what it is, dude? It's so,
it really is. Okay. So imagine me on top of my shoulders,
did they shoot Brokeback mountain on the back of them?
Maybe it was a long time ago and my shoulders weren't as beefy.
But you guarantee if they made a sequel, they would be back there right now.
And imagine me on top of you and sweat stripping, and it's all good.
And whether you're a male or female, let's say you're a male. I don't give a.
We're still, you know, I never understood really how gay guys could do it.
Not doggy-style.
Cause it's kind of weird to me if the guy's on his back and the other guys on
top of him and then that guy's kind of Dick is just like flopping around or
whatever. I don't know. Does he jerk off or do you do it?
Hey dude, I don't know. But if you want real, listen to NPR,
but if you want the really real, stay tuned to my babies.
Cause this is the that MPR should be talking about when gay guys not
is the guy on the bottoms, Dick flopping around. That's all I want to know.
Okay. But my point is I lost my train of thought. I lost my train of thought.
I lost my train of thought. Oh yeah, I got it.
I'm sexy because if I'm on top of you and if you're a dude,
let's say your name Hank or whatever.
And I'm on top of you and your flopping around and I'm doing the slow controlled
swoop down mode movements. Right? I don't want to say I'm known for, but I,
I know I do them. And then all of a sudden,
my wisp of hair goes in front of my eyes. That's it, dude. Splurting everywhere.
Everybody's sweating everywhere.
Even people that aren't involved in the sex come in and like, Whoa.
And they start splitting and slipping and falling and hurting their tailbones.
Cause that's what happens. Dope dude, girls and guys,
and then Jeremy Renner comes in and goes, Oh my God.
[Inaudible].
Sensational. Sensational. I'm a DJ dude.
These DJs are doing live streams on Instagram because of the pandemic dude.
Not fun. The whole dude.
It's not fun that there, if it's at least,
if you're one of those guys that likes to unset out,
at least do it there and take Molly and be like, Oh, I love him. The beat.
I could feel the beat. I could feel the beat. Dude. Imagine being at home,
watching mighty mouse or whatever the his name is on the.
Does he still wear his thing? Minnie mouse? The is that guy's name? Mouse,
DJ head dab mouse, dead mouse
dude. Dead mouse.
So by like we're here, I just turned 21 this year. So I'm here to party.
So it's kinda disappointing, but we're just making the most of it.
We met these other people in our little Airbnb spot.
So we're just hanging out with them.
First. His story ever, dude,
think the King King King King.
I was a grenade Dude.
That right there. Come on. What is it?
I just turned 21 this year. So I'm here to party. So it's kinda disappointing,
but we're just making the most of it.
We met these other people in our little Airbnb spot.
So we're just hanging out with them and trying to get drunk before everything
closed.
That's the grenade. Did you knew I was going to do an acronym?
You knew it was only a matter of time dude. Anyway. Um, how does she ride?
She's the female MNM dude. Yeah.
I mean we planned this a long time ago when it was the fun I'm putting there.
I mean, we plan this lot.
I mean,
we played in this a long time and it was kind of up in the air if we were still
going,
but I just turned 21 for me and the pony it's disappointing,
but we'll just make them, most of them have it.
People in our little ambient beast plants will do the thing and not with them
and trying to get right before the, the class
a.